>> Tucker: TARA REID’S
SEXUAL ASSAULT ALLEGATION
AGAINST HER FORMER BOSS
JOE BIDEN HAS NOT BEEN PROVEN,
LIKELY HAD NEVER WILL BE.
IT HAPPENED AN AWFULLY LONG TIME
AGO, SHE SAYS.
BUT NEWLY DISCOVERED EVIDENCE
FROM ALMOST 30 YEARS AGO OFFERS
A SURPRISING SUPPORT FOR REED’S
CLAIM, THIS CAME ALMOST OUT OF
NOWHERE.
A CLIP FROM "LARRY KING LIVE,"
THE OLD TO 9:00 P.M. SHOW ON
CNN, FEATURES A CALL FROM A
WOMAN REID TOLD REPORTERS IS HER
MOTHER.
WATCH THIS.
>> SAN LUIS CALIFORNIA, HELLO.
>> HELLO, I’M WONDERING WHAT
STAFFER COULD DO BESIDES GO TO
THE PRESS IN WASHINGTON.
MY DAUGHTER HAS JUST LEFT THERE.
AFTER WORKING FOR A PROMINENT
SENATOR AND COULD NOT GET
THROUGH WITH HER PROBLEMS AT
ALL.
THE ONLY THING SHE COULD HAVE
DONE WAS GO TO THE PRESS AND SHE
CHOSE NOT TO DO IT OUT OF
RESPECT FOR HIM.
>> SHE HAD A STORY TO TELL, BUT
OUT OF RESPECT FOR THE PERSON
SHE WORKED FOR SHE DIDN’T TELL
IT.
>> THAT’S TRUE.
>> Tucker: THAT’S FASCINATING.
RICH McCUE IS A LONGTIME
REPORTER WHO HAS BEEN ON THIS
STORY AND A LOT OF BIG STORIES,
THANKS SO MUCH FOR COMING ON
TONIGHT.
WE JUST LAY OUT THE FACTS AS WE
KNOW THEM AND THE ALLEGATIONS.
>> TARA REID WORKED FOR
JOE BIDEN IN 1992 AND 1993 FOR
ABOUT EIGHT MONTHS, SHE SAID AT
THE TIME SHE FACED
SEXUAL HARASSMENT FROM HIM, AND
SHE COMPLAINED ABOUT IT AND IT
FELL ON DEAF EARS.
SHE SAID SHE WENT IN AND FILED A
COMPLAINT OUTSIDE OF HIS OFFICE,
SOME SENATORIAL OFFICE THAT
WOULD HANDLE THESE THINGS.
AROUND THAT SAME TIME, SHE SAYS
SHE WAS ASKED TO DELIVER HIM A
GYM BAG AND ONE OF THE SENATE
BUILDINGS AND SHE BROUGHT IT TO
HIM, AND SHE SAYS IT WAS A WARM
SPRING DAY, A HOT SPRING DAY,
SHE SAYS THAT HE ATTACKED HER IN
A CORE DOOR.
IT WASN’T A PRIVATE OFFICE OR
ANYTHING, ATTACKED HER AND
ASSAULTED HER.
SHE CAME FORWARD TO
SHE MAY HAVE TOLD SOME OTHERS,
SHE CAME OUT LAST YEAR AND TOLD
PART OF HER STORY TO A LOCAL
PAPER IN CALIFORNIA.
AND A FEW WEEKS AGO, SHE CAME
OUT WITH HER FULL OBLIGATIONS.
AN ARTICLE AND PODCAST, AND
SINCE THEN EVERYONE HAS BEEN
EXAMINING THE VERACITY OF HER
CLAIMS.
>> Tucker: LET ME CLARIFY
SOMETHING.
ALL OF THIS IS KIND OF A
MISMATCH WHEN YOU TALK ABOUT
SEXUAL ASSAULT AND
SEXUAL HARASSMENT, SHE IS NOT
ADJUSTING HE SAID SOMETHING
VULGAR, HE’S SAYING WE SHE
SAYING HE GRABBED HER, IS THAT
CORRECT?
>> THAT’S CORRECT.
>> Tucker: THAT PUTS IT IN A
DIFFERENT CATEGORY THAN A LOT OF
THE STORIES WE SEE HERE.
TELL US ABOUT THIS CALL TO
LARRY KING, WHERE DID THAT CLIP
COME FROM?
>> SHE TOLD ME ABOUT THIS, IN
THE PROCESS OF REPORTING THIS
YOU’RE ALWAYS TRYING TO FIGURE
OUT HOW TO KILL A STORY.
IF YOU CAN KILL IT, THEN YOU
DON’T DO IT.
I WAS ALWAYS TRYING TO TRACK
DOWN THIS CLIP.
WITHOUT WORKING AT CNN, I
COULDN’T GO IN THERE.
TODAY, AND ENTERPRISING PhD
STUDENT, A WOMAN SENT A NOTE TO
MYSELF SAYING HEY, I THINK I
FOUND IT.
AND I THINK RYAN RESPONDED TO
HER QUICKER THAN I DID, WE GOT
THIS MOMENT THIS AFTERNOON WHERE
WE BOTH REALIZED THERE WAS THIS
VIDEO FOUND.
AND HE PUBLISHED IT, WE ACTUALLY
TALKED BUT HE PUBLISHED THE
STORY.
THE REST IS HISTORY.
>> Tucker: THAT’S AMAZING.
A DECADE BEFORE YOUTUBE, SO IT’S
NOT EASY TO FIND CABLE NEWS
CLIPS FROM 1993.
RICH McCUE, THANK YOU FOR THE